well more than 350,000 migrants without
valid immigration papers and refugees
came to the European Union in 2016 the
European border and Coastguard Agency
Frontex is responsible for protecting
the --use external borders were joined
now from our DW studio in Brussels by
the head of Frontex Fabrice leisure a
welcome to the show thanks so much for
your time today you know thanks to the
eu-turkey deal that was supposed to be a
halt to migrants crossing into the EU
from Turkey why are so many still making
the trip well the the you turkey deal
was successful in the sense that now the
the number of irregular migrants
irregular border crossings has dropped
significantly we have approximately 100
people arriving per day while before the
deal we had more than 2500 per day the
the trouble now is that they are as you
as you as you said many migrants waiting
in the on the islands approximately
15,000 or even more are waiting for the
asylum procedure
frontex is worried about the
humanitarian situation I have been
reporting this situation for weeks to to
the authorities
Commissioner ramappa law said that the
Commission gave fundings to Greek
authorities and humanitarian
organizations in order to improve the
living conditions of the of the migrants
there so the the problem is a
humanitarian one and as you showed well
there is a problem for instance no
school frontex
mandate is is of course not a
humanitarian mandate but we contributed
for instance two weeks ago we made our
mobile office available for school so
that you know migrants kids could have
some some lessons there okay we're
seeing some progress in that area mr.
LaVey
but still some 181 thousand migrants
arrived in Italy in 2016 from North
Africa
across the so-called Mediterranean route
now that's the highest number ever
recorded and it's 20% more than a 2015
it's not a problem that's being solved
the migration flow is continuing them
what do you say to that well correct the
the main concern in terms of new
arrivals of irregular migrants so let's
say irregular border crossings is the
flow from Libya to Italy and and there
we see indeed an increase by 20% in 2016
compared to 2015 the reason for that is
the situation in Libya we we have
situations where we have 100 thousands
of migrants waiting there the smugglers
and the traffickers are very active in
in Libya on the smugglers if I could
jump in there mr. LaVey what what about
the smugglers is that is the EU doing
anything to crackdown on them in Libya
for example well in well in the course
of its activity Frontex contribute to
the fight against criminal organisations
we collect personal data for instance
when we disembark the migrants in Italy
in the hot spot we debrief them we
screen them and during this interviews
we can collect personal data which are
relevant for investigations if they give
names or phone number or license plate
or whatever that can be used by police
investigations and then this personal
data are shared with Europol and with
Italian police that's welcome and I'd
like to jump in on on the identification
issue if I could at the largest group of
migrants coming in are from Nigeria and
and Guinea they don't have any right to
refugee status they would be economic
migrants is of Frontex returning them
how does frontex deal with the refugees
who are economic refugees in in frontex
monday there is indeed the possibility
and also the the duty to to support
member states in
irregular migrants so economic migrants
after they they are denied residence
permit or asylum status in 2016
front X tripled the number of returned
people we organized 230 joint return
flights from Europe to let's say non EU
countries and we returned up to ten
thousand seven hundred economic migrants
back to countries of origin but this is
a national decision meaning that we can
only return economic or irregular
migrants if there is a national decision
made for instance by Italian authorities
in the Italian hotspot or by Greek
authorities in the Greek hotspot but we
can also support other member states and
for instance I can report that we have
now a very good an extensive intensive
cooperation with Germany and there we we
see that we we support also Germany with
with the return operations mr. lazarey
I'd like to ask you about the the front
tax efforts at sea in the Mediterranean
are you going to step up your efforts
there to stop the flow of migrants and
in boats that are often not suited to
that journey at all where we're seeing
an incredible loss of life at sea well
at present time we have 12 vessels
deployed by Frontex
in our operation on Triton operation in
in Italy between Italy and and Libya we
also have the same number of vessels in
Greece to make sure that there are no
search and rescue case needed there we
have saved lives up to four thousand and
yeah 40,000 40,000 lives were saved last
year by by frontex the problem is when
the migrants are at sea it's too late
because they they put their life at risk
so that there is a need to fix the
problem in cooperation with African
countries and from take is going to
deploy in spring this year
an officer - neow - neow we're going to
post him or her in EMA with the
possibility to cooperate with other EU
actions there the you cap siyul mission
for instance so we are trying now to
have this cooperation on the African
continent in order to save lives because
we also have to think about lives lost
in the desert because everybody's
focused ok what I Mediterranean but
there is a lot of risk in the desert as
well and like to ask you a last brief
question there mr. lazarey and that is
what do you need most right now do you
need diplomatic help or do you need more
naval vessels more people on the ground
in North Africa in desert areas as well
which one's more important right now
from the EU member states to help
Frontex I think to help from text and
and more generally - to help the
European Union to be more efficient in
in tackling this Libyan problem and I
think we need a political input we need
diplomatic efforts in order to really
change the game because the situation in
Libya for instance Frontex contributed
to the training of the Libyan Coast
Guard but of course as long as there is
no let's say effective possibility for
Libyan Coast Guard - - to monitor the
waters or - to carry out border controls
then we are still in in trouble so what
we need right now is something which is
more at political level political
decision in the EU and diplomatic
cooperation with African countries mr.
LaVey thank you so very much for being
with us today thank you for your
comments that was Fabrice Alicia he the
head of front tax that's the European
border and Coast Guard Protection Agency
thank you very much for being with us
thank you very much